voilà retour en direct sur l'antenne de
public sénat
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont démarrer d'ici
quelques secondes cette fois puisque le
tour de france ça y est passé de france
3 france 2 donc france 3 comme public
sénat vont pouvoir vous diffuser ces
questions en direct avec je vous le
rappelle pour commencer une question du
sénateur socialiste jean-pierre café sur
le livret a alors que le gouvernement a
annoncé aujourd'hui que le taux a été
ramené à 1 25%
c'est jean marc ayrault qui va répondre
à cette question qu'on écoute tout de
suite 2 minutes 30 pour la question mais
également pour la réponse pour les
ministres pour la première question la
parole est à monsieur jean-pierre café
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre nous avons appris ce
matin que le taux du livret a passerait
au 1er août de 1 75 à 1 25%
avant de vous faire part des précisions
que je souhaiterais à ce sujet il me
semble bon de rappeler quelques éléments
sur cette question à laquelle nos
concitoyens sont très attentifs la
baisse du taux du livret a ne doit pas
être analysés en effet de manière isolée
mais replacé dans la stratégie
financières et fiscales que le
gouvernement mène depuis un an ce taux
de 1 25%
c'est la rémunération qui était sale du
livret a en 2009 la baisse annoncée
aujourd'hui paraissait aux yeux des
experts comme indispensables notamment
du fait du faible niveau des taux
d'intérêt du marché monétaire et de la
baisse de l'inflation qui sont
d'ailleurs de bonnes nouvelles toutefois
là où certains auraient souhaité une
baisse plus importante du taux du livret
a le niveau de 1 25% semble constituer
un bon compromis entre deux impératifs
le premier impératif est de protéger les
petits épargnants qui sont des millions
à choisir dans le lait livré à un moyen
de sécuriser leurs épargnants se livrer
comme le ldd ont d'ailleurs connu une
seconde jeunesse grâce au relèvement de
leur plafond puisque pour la seule année
2012 ce sont environ 50 milliards
d'euros qui ont été collectés
un chiffre à comparer aux 10 8 milliards
dès 2011 le second impératif c'est
d'utiliser le livret a comme force de
frappe pour relancer notre économie
c'est vrai pour le choc d'offre en
matière de logement les objectifs
ambitieux mais nécessaire
deux cent cinquante mille logements
sociaux nouveaux parents nécessite une
politique financière de soutien
dynamique et la baisse du taux du livret
a permettra d'alimenter les besoins en
la matière c'est également vrai pour la
bataille pour la croissance que nous
menons les fonds du livret a en partie
réinjecter par la caisse des dépôts dans
le financement des territoires et des
collectivités locales sont une nécessité
absolue
à l'heure où l'accès au crédit bancaire
ce temps pour celle ci car soutenir
l'investissement public local
c'est soutenir les carnets de commandes
de milliers d'entreprises dans le
bâtiment les réseaux haut débit les
infrastructures en général nous
soutenons donc cette politique cohérente
et monsieur le premier ministre je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez d'une
part nous indiquer les conséquences que
pourrait avoir cette baisse du taux du
livret a dans pour le financement de
notre économie que plus largement pour
la vie de nos concitoyens et d'autre
part comment s'inscrit cette mesure dans
la politique économique que vous
conduisez merci la parole est à monsieur
jean marc ayrault premier ministre
monsieur le président du sénat je
voudrais d'abord mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs vous remercier monsieur le
président ainsi que mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs puisque nous
arrivons bientôt à la fin de cette
session extraordinaire
j'ai conscience que le gouvernement vous
a demandé beaucoup de travail et vous
avez répondu avec votre disponibilité
habituelle est enrichi par aux
contributions le travail des projets de
loi du gouvernement donc je voulais tout
simplement vous en remercier et puis
monsieur café vous avez posé une
question qui est très judicieuse parce
qu'effectivement ce matin pierre
moscovici et cécile duflot dans une
conférence de presse ont annoncé la
décision du gouvernement concernant le
taux du livret à l'épargné populaire
c'est essentiel et le livret a comme le
livret développement durable sont
particulièrement appréciés par les
françaises et les français et c'est vrai
parce que c'est une épargne garantie par
l'état
et ce n'est pas rien dans ces périodes
parfois d'incertitude
et puis je crois que il faut pas oublier
que le livret a comme le livret
développement durable contribue
fortement à l'investissement dans le
logement dans la rénovation urbaine mais
aussi au fort faveur des collectivités
locales
donc comme vous le savez aussi le taux
du livret a est calculé en fonction de
l'inflation il ya des règles le
gouverneur de la banque de france donne
son avis tous les six mois pour tenir
compte justement d'évolution de
l'inflation et par ailleurs le
gouvernement à sa suite des engagements
qu'ils avaient pris le président de la
république a augmenté substantiellement
le plafond du livret a et doubler le
plafond du livret développement durable
donc il ya maintenant aujourd'hui des
disponibilités financières
on va dire des liquidités qui sont
nécessaires au financement de notre
économie au financement de nos
investissements dans le logement et dans
les infrastructures et dans les ans les
investissements publics
donc c'est cette situation qui a conduit
le gouvernement à prendre ses
responsabilités
garantir le pouvoir d'achat des
épargnants telle était notre
préoccupation
si nous avions appliqué
mécaniquement comme c'est la règle
l'augmentation et l'actualisation du
taux du livret a c'est 20 1% qu'il
aurait fallu adopter 1% qui aurait fait
une rémunération comme c'est la règle
environ 2 0 25% supplémentaires au taux
de l'inflation qui est de 0,8 constater
et bien le gouvernement a souhaité
maintenir un niveau supérieur de pouvoir
d'achat du livret a c'est pourquoi le
taux de 1 25% a été décidé mais en même
temps comme l'inflation est faible et
messieurs jeanpierre café l'a rappelé
c'est une bonne chose
d'un côté maintien et même amélioration
du pouvoir d'achat de rémunération du
livret a et du livret développement
durable
mais de l'autre côté et c'est ce que la
caisse des dépôts a décidé puisque cette
conférence de presse a eu lieu en
présence du directeur général de la
caisse jean pierre jouyet c'est comment
provoquer un choc supplémentaire en
faveur de l'investissement et en
particulier dans le logement où nous
avons des besoins très importants donc
la bouffée d'oxygène que cela représente
pour le logement social c'est 600
millions six cent millions et qui va se
traduire pour les prêts de la caisse des
dépôts dans les six prochains mois pour
le logement social par une baisse du
coût de financement supplémentaire de 0
25% ce qui fera un effort global en
faveur du logement social par une sorte
de prime pour ce qu'ils en seront de
nouveau projet de 120 120 millions
d'euros qui concernera également la
rénovation thermique
actuellement il existe des prêts à 1%
pour la rénovation thermique
il a été décidé de porter ces prêts à 0
5% donc on ne peut pas faire plus bas si
on ne veut pas se dire et paient des
frais excessifs pour la caisse des
dépôts
donc c'est un geste politique
extrêmement important et concernant les
collectivités territoriales cette
semaine j'ai rencontré toutes les
associations d'élus des communes de
toutes les tailles des départements et
des régions et nous avons adopté les
conclusions
de ce qu'on appelle le pacte de
confiance et de responsabilité
le gouvernement a demandé à chaque à
chacun de contribuer à l'effort
d'amélioration des comptes publics et
collectivités locales ont été sollicités
en même temps il faut stabiliser leurs
recettes sécuriser les départements par
rapport à la dépense sociale et l'accord
qui a été passé dans le bon sens et je
remercie tous ceux qui ont contribué de
même que pour les régions même s'il
reste encore un certain nombre de points
de détail à définir et ce que nous est
en sommes en train de terminer et en
même temps les collectivités locales -
on parlé de leurs attentes pour
poursuivre leur politique
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures de transport leurs
investissements dans les réseaux d'eau
et d'assainissement et dans d'autres
investissements comme le numérique et
ont plaidé depuis des mois pour à la
fois des emprunts longs et des taux les
plus bas possibles le gouvernement
s'était déjà engagé à le faire et
l'évolution du taux du livret a va
permettre d'améliorer encore la
proposition puisque actuellement les
taux qui sont proposés sont de 3 0 5%
ils ont être porté à compter du 1er août
à 2,25 pour cent
je crois que c'était une information
extrêmement importante pour nos
territoires
j'ai annoncé le 9 juillet dernier un
grand plan d'investissement dans
beaucoup de secteurs dont les secteurs
des transports et en particulier les
transports ferroviaires ça concerne tous
les territoires j'ai annoncé également
que à la rentrée le gouvernement va
engager la négociation pour les contrats
de plan avec les régions l'ensemble des
collectivités
justement pour mettre en oeuvre ces
investissements il est bien évident que
si les empreintes sont plus longs mais
prêts sont plus longs et que les taux
d'intérêt sont au plus bas
alors les collectivités locales
retrouveront des marges de manoeuvre
dont elles ont besoin pour les leurs
investissements et des investissements
utiles à nos territoires pour la
cohésion sociale et territoriale et pour
le développement du pays
merci la parole est à madame mireille
schurch pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen merci monsieur le
président monsieur mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues et ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
monsieur le ministre vendredi dernier
nous avons tous été saisie par l'émotion
face à l'accident sur la ligne paris
limoges que je connais bien ailleurs en
gare de brétigny sur orge
ce mardi c'est un wagon d'un train de
fret transportant du gravier qui a
déraillé à la suite d'une rupture
d'essieu à saintes
les enquêtes sont en cours et il ne faut
pas ici anticiper les conclusions qui
seront remises pour autant la question
de l'état de l'infrastructure
ferroviaire dans notre pays
support matériel de l'exécution du
service public ferroviaire est posée
avec acuité le constat du
sous-investissement chronique dans les
infrastructures de transport ferroviaire
est unanime
depuis vingt ans les budgets de
maintenance n'ont cessé de baisser
tout comme la contribution aux
infrastructures de l'état rff et la sncf
sous les wallons sous les injonctions de
l'état actionnaire ont été appelés à des
économies drastiques contraintes de
diminuer le nombre de cheminots et de
rogner sur certaines dépenses courantes
essentiel l'objectif du précédent
gouvernement
résident est exclusivement dans
l'ouverture du rail à la concurrence et
au vu du quatrième paquet ferroviaire ce
mouvement s'accélère
comment l'accepter au regard de
l'expérience notamment termes de
sécurité que nous avons en ce domaine
al'inverse et alors que la réforme
ferroviaire se dessine nous estimons que
si celle ci doit prioritairement réunir
la famille ferroviaire dans le cadre
d'un groupe public intégré elle doit
dans le même mouvement
s'adosser à des engagements financiers
forts concrets et tangibles
alors que le budget de l'état etc en
baisse constante des annonces
intéressantes ont été faite le 9 juillet
dernier pour le financement du système
ferroviaire
malheureusement elles sont peu précises
notamment en ce qui concerne les
ressources nouvelles d'eux
afif tu es la répartition de l'effort
entre privés publics et collectivités
pire ces financement repose aussi pour
partie sur la vente des actifs de l'état
monsieur le ministre
quand l'état s'engage ratier
concrètement pour la reprise de la dette
de rff
par quels financements concrets
alimenter vous la fif pourquoi ne pas
remettre en cause la privatisation des
concessions d'autoroutes qui la prive à
l'échelle des dix années à venir
de plus de 12 milliards soit le montant
des investissements d'avenir
je vous remercie merci monsieur frédéric
cuvillier ministre des transports de la
mer et de la pêche
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice mireille
schurch merci pour votre question qui me
permets ici dans cet hémicycle de
renouveler toute l'émotion et
l'accompagnement à l'adresse des
familles des victimes
j'ai nommé monsieur selb hier comme
coordonnateur c'est un haut
fonctionnaire d'état permettant d'être
dans l'accompagnement des familles c'est
important de ne pas perdre 7
cet accompagnement nécessaire face à
pareille situation est par ailleurs je
tiens à saluer la mobilisation comme l'a
fait monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président de la république
sur place de toute la famille cheminote
bénévoles aux volontaires qui s'est
mobilisé l'ensemble des services de
sécurité de secours ça a été un geste de
solidarité énorme
vous avez raison de souligner que l'on
ne peut faire le rapprochement entre ce
qui est accidentelle il y a trois
enquêtes qui sont engagés notamment
celle du bureau enquête accident est la
situation du réseau ferroviaire que vous
qualifiez de vsu vétusté très
précisément en effet le constat qui en a
été fait des notes prises de
responsabilité a été la réactualisation
de l'étude de l'école polytechnique de
lausanne qui fait référence en la
matière et qui a confirmé la dégradation
continue depuis des dizaines d'années
faute d'investissements suffisants des
infrastructures de transport pourquoi
tout simplement parce que des
mobilisations financière est souvent à
crédit ont été
mobilisés sur des projets de prestige au
détriment de ce qui fait la réalité du
quotidien le transport du quotidien et
de ce point de vue monsieur le premier
ministre le 9 juillet a annoncé une
mobilisation forte à la fois des moules
des financements de l'état mais
également des moyens qui seront dégagées
par rff
à côté des deux milliards 2 milliards 5
supplémentaires sont ajoutées pour à la
fois la modernisation et l'entretien du
réseau ferroviaire dans le contrat de
plan état région ce sont 500 millions
supplémentaires sur le volet ferroviaire
c'est à dire une hausse de 40%
nécessaires à la sécurité à la
modernisation ou parler d'une politique
qui a été menée jusqu'à présent
privatisation dès notre prise de
fonction nous avons refusé une
anticipation d'une privatisation qui ne
nous est d'ailleurs pas imposé par
l'europe et donc la france a été très
clair sur 7 sur le refus de cette
anticipation est par ailleurs la réforme
ferroviaire aura pour enjeu c'est
l'orientation du gouvernement de réunir
la gestion des infrastructures de
transport ferroviaire de faire en sorte
que rff et sncf puisse ensemble sous un
groupe unifié le faire en sorte que nous
puissions être plus efficaces et de
répondre aux enjeux des territoires
merci la parole à présent assurément
valent pour le groupe eads
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des transports
le groupe rdse auquel j'appartiens est
très attentif à la question des
infrastructures qu'elles soient
routières ferroviaires et aériennes et
fluviales et ses surnoms trinity à
s'initia tive que le sénat avait pu donc
discuter et même parfois compter c'est
le schéma national des infrastructures
de transport qui nous a été présenté il
ya deux ans comme cela a été précisé
l'accident de vendredi dernier a mise en
lumière de manière dramatique certes la
question essentielle de l'entretien des
infrastructures cet entretien est
désormais clairement affiché comme une
priorité par le gouvernement nous en
réjouissons et bien sûr nous félicitons
aussi cela vient d'être rappelé que
monsieur le premier ministre il ya
quelques jours et donc annoncé un
programme d'investissement annuel
le 5 milliards d'euros consacrés à la
modernisation au développement de nos
réseaux cette décision est la preuve
tangible de l'engagement du gouvernement
nous ou contre nous y souscrivons bien
entendu car il n'est plus l'heure de
lancer tous azimuts des lignes dans
grande vitesse nous n'avons plus les
moyens ou promettre de 145 millions
d'euros comme c'était le cas dans le
snit sans qu'il y ait en face un
financement prévu à cet égard le travail
effectué à votre demande monsieur le
ministre par la commission durant pour
hiérarchiser le catalogue
d'investissement établis par le procès
de précédents gouvernements et en
programmation l'exécution programmée
l'exécution est un réel progrès vient
maintenant le temps des décisions est là
monsieur le ministre je vous demande
d'entendre le désespoir des territoires
enclavés et souvent des territoires
ruraux de questions en particulier me
vient à l'esprit
la première concerne les routes
nationales éligibles au pdmi elles font
partie d'ailleurs d'une liste qui a été
donc effectivement repéré par le rapport
du rond mais qui a été exclue de ce
rapport et qui donc sera forcément
financé par d'épidémie et cpd me nous le
savons aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
cas ne représentent plus que 40%
engagements de l'état
il est bien évident que ces territoires
ruraux en cave et ne pourront pas
apporté les 60% complémentaires je ne
citerai que la rn 88 cents 22 20 21 et
d'autres dont ma seconde question
s'inscrit dans la suite de cette
interrogation puisque dans le rapport
l'excellent rapport de mes collègues
jacques mézard rémy pointereau qui
affichait une dizaine de propositions
nous nous interrogeons monsieur le
ministre sur les critères que vous
envisagez de retenir pour affecter ces
crédits destinés à la remise à niveau
des infrastructures existantes et donc
que nous interrogeons car ces mêmes
territoires devront aussi beaucoup
s'investir pour se désenclaver sur le
plan numérique
alors monsieur le ministre nous
attendons sur ces deux questions de
votre part des réponses concrètes merci
merci monsieur le ministre fournier
cuvillier merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président vale ainsi que
l'indiqué un instant monsieur le premier
ministre
une mobilisation de l'état aux côtés des
collectivités va être lancé c'est
d'ailleurs en ce sens qu'il a demandé
que le volet transports infrastructures
mobilité
de la contractualisation entre les
territoires c'est à dire l'état les
régions les départements les
agglomérations puis 7 anticipé de sorte
que d'ici à la fin d'année
la priorisation des investissements
publics puissent être actée et faire en
sorte que nous puissions avoir une
approche qui souhaite une approche
coordonnée en fonction des attentes des
territoires et éviter qu'il y ait comme
vous le soulignez cette situation
paradoxale qui indiquait jusqu'à ces
dernières années des investissements
importants sur des grandes
infrastructures au détriment des
territoires au détriment de certains
territoires qui sont enclavés encore ou
qui ne bénéficient pas de
d'infrastructures susceptibles d'assurer
l'égalité territoriale avec cécile
duflot nous travaillons ardemment à
cette question d'ailleurs vous soulignez
la situation d'épidémie en d'autres
termes les travaux routiers
les travaux routiers ont été engagées en
promesses à hauteur de 700 millions
d'euros
il aurait fallu chaque année 700
millions d'euros de la part de l'état
pour pouvoir tout simplement répondre
aux engagements qui étaient les siens
seuls 350 millions c'est-à-dire la
moitié ont été attribués en dotation
c'est à dire que nous avons au moins un
retard de l'équivalent d'un contrat de
pdm
il faut rattraper ce retard il faut que
nous puissions tout en préservant la
nécessité de moderniser les
infrastructures ferroviaires je viens
d'y répondre
renouveler le matériel roulant à hauteur
de 500 millions d'euros le pôle le
premier ministre s'est engagé à ce que
le matériel roulant les corail qui
datent souvent de 1975 soit tous
renouvelés d'ici à 2025 et que nous
puissions avoir un programme routier qui
en fonction des territoires nous
permettre de répondre aux priorités
c'est à dire que c'est dans ce dialogue
la confiance entre les collectivités tu
veux nous pourrons déterminer les
priorités une priorité d'une région ne
correspondant pas nécessairement à celle
d'une autre région et je suis persuadé
que d'ici à la fin de l'année nous
pourrons avoir enfin de la parole de
l'état une appréciation qui soit de
sérieux et de conviction et d'éviter que
ce soit
comme nous l'avons trouvé les schémas
d'infrastructures de transport comme
autant de promesses à crédit qui ne font
que finalement fragilisé l'engagement et
la parole de l'état est globalement la
parole publique
il faut du cru du sérieux il faut du
pragmatisme et il faut surtout une
réponse aux attentes de nos citoyens sur
nos territoires
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
roger karoutchi pour le groupe ump ce
président monsieur le ministre je pense
que dans tous les groupes et tous les
élus ont naturellement été extrêmement
marqué par l'accident de brétigny marqué
aussi il faut le dire quand c'est bien
par la responsabilité la transparence du
président la sncf
mais monsieur le ministre vous avez fait
et c'est logique en période de disette
budgétaire vous avez fait des choix
d'investissement alors je suis pas cet
après-midi-là proposer une question là
dessus on peut dire d'accord pas
d'accord pour l'abandon de telle ou
telle ligne
en réalité nous avons est depuis
longtemps un système ferroviaire ou pour
faire
soyons directs du tgv on n'a pas mis
beaucoup de moyens sur le reste dans le
cas de l'île de france soit la même fait
mieux
entre 1980 et 2000 on apprit
l'amortissement du matériel roulant en
ile-de-france pour le mettre sur le tgv
et on l'a pas remis sur l'île de france
donc tout ça et là sincèrement quels que
soient les gouvernements un gauche
droite
tout le monde a fait ça est la sncf
faisait ça aujourd'hui nous sommes en
face d'une situation où dans toute la
france en ile de france comme dans toute
la france des lignes sont usées alors
j'entends bien j'ai entendu le président
de rff dire il ya aucun problème
le fait que le système soit très anciens
ou usé ne présente aucun risque aucune
difficulté
pardon de vous dire que je ne crois
guère cela je pense que l'usure fini par
présenter des risques est en tout cas
des inconvénients majeurs pour ceux qui
sont transportés retards annulations
panne se multiplient il n'y a pas
seulement les accidents graves
il ya aussi le problème constant en ile
de france comme dans toute la france
des retards et des difficultés pour tous
les voyageurs
mais monsieur le ministre il avait été
évoquée en ile de france et dans toute
la france un plan d'urgence sur
l'entretien sur ce qu'on appelait les
points noirs les points noirs c'était
les aiguillages les plus anciens
c'étaient les systèmes les plus
difficiles c'étaient les lignes que même
les associations d'usagers appellent
eux-mêmes les lignes poubelle je parle
pas du matériel je parle bien des lignes
ne serait-il pas temps monsieur le
ministre de définir dans le cadre du
budget que vous évoquez sur l'entretien
d'avoir un plan d'urgence sur les points
noirs du système ferroviaire pour faire
en sorte au moins que tous les éléments
tous les lieux de vrai danger soit réglé
très vite
au delà de l'entretien normal de
l'ensemble des lignes
merci monsieur frédéric cuvillier merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur caoutchouc précisément les
propos que je viens de tenir en relais
de ceux du monsieur le premier ministre
souligne ce que vous constatez
d'ailleurs c'est à dire les méfaits ou
les carences d'une politique intérieure
qui a été menée qui est celle de la
concentration je reprends vos propos de
financement sur des grands ouvrages de
type lgv non que les grandes
infrastructures ne soient pas nécessaire
elle leçons mais de lancer un rythme qui
est un rite à rythme qu'ils étaient bien
supérieurs en nos capacités a fait que
nous n'avions pas et vous n'aviez pas la
possibilité de financer dans le même
temps le réseau existant le ffd notre
prise de fonction j'ai demandé à rff de
pouvoir mobiliser un plan d'urgence
c'est précisément les deux milliards 5
supplémentaires qui s'additionneront aux
2 milliards de modernisation d'entretien
du réseau
c'est à dire que là où il y avait un
budget d'un milliard 4 sous les
précédentes années nous sommes à 5,5
milliards annuels de modernisation du
réseau classique
c'est vrai également dans le cadre de
l'île de france ou demain le premier
ministre avec le président de
région nous cécile duflot et moi
assisteront à la signature de
l'engagement financier sur le plan de
mobilisation qui en marge du grand
nouveau grand paris permettra de
d'engager 7 milliards de travaux de
régularité et d'amélioration du du
réseau est important de pouvoir répondre
sur ces questions d'entretien nombre
qu'il fallait faire confusion entre
entretien et sécurité bien évidemment
s'il y avait des vignes qui posait des
problèmes de sécurité
elle serait fermée ou bien évidemment
les mesures sont prises lorsque
certaines situations amène à ce qu'eads
et la sécurité soient mises en cause
notamment l'abaissement du seuil de
vitesse c'est assez régulier donc
lorsque nous parlons je le dis parce
qu'il faut être précis sur la
terminologie lorsque nous parlons de
lignes malades
il s'agit bien de lignes sensibles sur
la régularité sur le fait comme vous
l'indiquez vous même lorsque vous parlez
de problèmes de sécurité vous invoquez
des retards et des annulations ou des
pannes en l'occurrence ce ne sont pas
des critères de sécurité mais bien de
dysfonctionnement du réseau matériel
roulant qui sera renouvelée ou de
l'infrastructure elle même qui est
vieillissante et parfois vétustes mais
de ce point de vue il est important de
bien signaler que nous sommes sur le
réseau ferroviaire français
parmi les pays les plus sécurisés et
avec une infrastructure qui est les plus
sûrs d'europe
pour autant j'ai demandé au mois de mars
dernier à l'établissement public de
sécurité ferroviaire de bien vouloir me
rendre un rapport
je ne savais pas que l'actualité nous
amènerait à nous entretenir ainsi dans
cette situation mais le faire un point
précis des problèmes de sécurité et
d'organisation de la sécurité
ferroviaire ce rapport ne sera rendue
cet automne et nous pourrons adapter les
mesures nécessaires pour être au rendez
vous de ces enjeux qui sont des enjeux
indépendamment de nous conversons
monsieur les enjeux de territoire et de
la population
merci la parole est à présent la dame
muguette dini pour le groupe
udi uc merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre le président de la
république lors de son entretien
télévisé du 14 juillet dernier
appelle les français à l'optimisme et à
la confiance la reprise économique est
là nous dit il vous avez repris cette
affirmation à votre compte monsieur le
ministre
et nous aimerions savoir plus tous les
voyants économiques sont au rouge
la france est entrée depuis plus d'un
trimestre en récession nos exportations
s'effondrent et la pression fiscale sur
les ménages à briser l'élan de la
consommation
toutes les familles sont touchées par le
chômage tous nos concitoyens ont
désormais un proche qui se retrouvent
sans travail et cela représente
maintenant près de 11 % de la population
active
monsieur le ministre le rythme de
dégradation de notre tissu économique
s'accélère on ne compte plus le nombre
d'entreprises qui connaissent des
problèmes importants de trésorerie et
qui ne parviennent plus à trouver des
financements
on ne compte plus le nombre
d'entreprises liquide et chaque usine
qui ferme chaque commerce qui dépose le
bilan
signe l'échec de la politique économie
et du crédit d'impôt compétitivité qui
n'aura séduit que 6000 entreprises sur 2
millions il n'y aura pas non plus de
surprise venue de l'extérieur la demande
mondiale adressée à la france ne cesse
de se contracter
du fait des difficultés économiques des
pays émergents comme de nos voisins
européens qui sont nos premiers
partenaires commerciaux
nous sommes seuls face à nous mêmes et
face à notre incapacité d'oser l'airé
véritables réformes économiques et
sociales
dans ces conditions monsieur le ministre
comment pouvez-vous nous expliquer en
quoi la reprise est de retour comment
espérez vous faire croire que votre
politique économique et efficace
comment pouvez-vous faire croire à nos
concitoyens qu'une croissance économique
quasi nul pourrait créer assez d'emplois
pour répondre au drame social qui se
joue aujourd'hui dans tous les foyers de
notre pays
monsieur le ministre sur quels
instruments comptez-vous pour répondre
aux angoisses et à la défiance légitime
des français et des françaises à l'égard
de votre politique je vous remercie
merci la parole à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances madame la sénatrice me ghedini
merci de votre question
vous savez je trouve toujours
contestable que l'opposition se
saisissent des difficultés des français
afin de mettre ou de tenter de mettre en
difficulté le gouvernement alors que si
nous sommes à clé avec autant de force
au redressement de nos finances
publiques et de notre économie c'est
parce que vous vous avez laissé une
situation du pays extraordinairement
dégradé 5 5% de déficit public
un endettement qui s'est accru de 600
milliards d'euros en cinq ans vous me
parlez de notre commerce extérieur bon
quand nous sommes arrivés aux
responsables t d mais 70 milliards de
déficit du commerce extérieur alors que
les allemands font 160 milliards
d'excédents et quand moi j'étais du
gouverement lionel jospin
nous avons quitté les responsabilités le
commerce extérieur français et est
excédentaire et je ne voudrais pas la
renvoyer les uns ou les autres aux
chiffres du chômage
alors franchement je pense que
l'opposition devrait encore avoir de la
décence et de la pudeur qu'elle ne
devrait pas jouer sur des émotions
qu'elle ne devait pas de tenter
d'inquiéter davantage les français
après vous m'interrogez sur les raisons
pour lesquelles le président la
république s'est exprimé pour rendre
confiance aux français comme il l'a fait
le 14 juillet écoutez les faits sont
simples et je vais vous les donner
d'abord première chose c'est vrai la
france a connu deux trimestres de
récession
une c'est-à-dire deux trimestres de
croissance négative consécutive le
dernier trimestre 2012 et le premier
trimestre 2013
mais la france sort de la récession et
nous devons tous nous en réjouir oui le
deuxième trimestre 2013 sera une
croissance positive de 0 2% et des
signaux sont en train de clignoter
manière positive je pense à la
production industrielle je pense ne vous
en déplaise à la consommation des
ménages
je pense aussi à la demande extérieure
qui nous est adressé et ce gouvernement
est un gouvernement qui a engagé des
réformes structurelles que vous avez
toujours négligées réforme du marché du
travail la plus ambitieuse depuis 40 ans
vous ne l'avez pas fait réformes en
faveur de la compétitivité avec le
crédit d'impôt committee des emplois
vous ne l'avez pas fait
et vous confondez d'ailleurs le crédit
lui même avec son préfinancement
préfinancement qui atteindra cette année
je le dis ici les deux milliards d'euros
prévus et l'année prochaine ce sera pour
toutes les entreprises sur simple
déclaration alors arrêtez d'essayer de
décourager les gens regardaient au
contraire ce que nous faisons et je
reprendrai simplement pour finir ce qu'a
dit tout à l'heure le premier ministre
oui nous avons ce matin à la fois
soutenu le pouvoir d'achat ne l'est pas
impopulaire en donnant un petit coup de
pouce par rapport à la formule sur le
livret a mais nous avons fait autre
chose avec cécile duflot
nous avons pris les mesures pour le
logement social nous avons pris les
mesures pour la rénovation thermique
nous avons pris des mesures pour les
collectivités locales l'enveloppent de
près de 20 milliards d'euros pourra être
accessible un taux d'abstention de 2,25
pour cent
mobilisons-nous sso de nigré notre pays
nous avons besoin du collectif
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
desessard pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances
cette question concerne l'avenir du
crédit immobilier de france
monsieur le ministre comme moi vous êtes
attachés au principe de l'accession
sociale à la propriété et avec le cif
il s'agit de permettre à des ménages
modestes de souscrire des crédits
immobiliers alors même qu'ils ne
satisfont pas au formatage standard des
dossiers qu'un banques imposent les
banques commerciales
je suis attaché à l'accession sociale
heures de la propriété parce que c'est
une démarche de justice vis-à-vis de ce
public solvables indûment exclus du
marché
j'y suis attaché parce que le logement
des ménages modestes ne peux pas c'est
uniquement par le logement social
j'y suis attaché parce qu'en tant
qu'écologiste je crois à la
responsabilité et l'autonomie de
l'individu qui aura autant que possible
à coeur d' entretenir et valoriser son
logement
ce que la location permet plus
difficilement le crédit immobilier de
france a su développer en la matière une
expertise patente
fonté sur un accompagnement et 3 des
clients et un après
un appareillage assurantielle
sophistiqués
qui aboutit à un taux de sinistralité
équivalent à celui des grandes banques
commerciales
suite à la crise de liquidité du cif la
banque postale n'a repris qu'une partie
de ses activités
un seul produit le pass et distribuée
sans l'accompagnement personnalisé qui
faisait la spécificité du civ
une solution existe pourtant pour
préserver cette compétence la mise en
place d'une banque relais j'insiste sur
le fait technique qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une alternative à la résolution
ordonnée et la gestion extinctive du cif
mais c'est simplement une transition qui
serait certainement sous certaines
conditions acceptées par bruxelles donc
monsieur le ministre afin de sauvegarder
la compétence du cif en matière
d'accession sociale à la propriété
avez vous l'intention d'intervenir
auprès de la commission européenne pour
défendre cette entreprise française en
présentant un plan de résolution qui
intègre une banque relais
merci monsieur pierre moscovici monsieur
le sénateur jean désessard nous avons eu
l'occasion de nous entretenir à
plusieurs reprises dû siffler je connais
votre attachement à cette entreprise à
ses salariés vous savez que c'est aussi
une situation qui me préoccupe et dont
je m'occupe beaucoup depuis que je suis
dans ses responsabilités quelle est la
situation est alors un constat c'est que
le cif
nous l'avons trouvé dans une situation
très dégradée et que le précédent
gouvernement n'avait engagé aucune
mesure efficace pour y remédier et nous
étions en situation est las de devoir
constater si l'avion à j-1 sinistre
bancaire de grande ampleur qui aurait pu
avoir un impact systémique
alors évidemment à partir du mois de
septembre j'ai examiné mes services ont
décliné aussi toutes les solutions
possibles
nous avons cherché évidemment un
repreneur la solution que vous évoquez
d'une banque relais elle a évidemment
elle aussi était évoquée traités et
malheureusement ce que nous avons été
amenés à constater c'est que ça n'était
pas financièrement viable ou alors que
ça risquait d'apparaître comme une aide
d'état qui eût été totalement
incompatible avec le
droit communautaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle eh bien nous nous sommes
conformés à ces règles en décidant un
plan de résolution ordonnée qui prévoit
la mise en extinction du cif en dehors
bien sûr des activités viables qui sont
susceptibles d'intéresser un repreneur
qui pourront être cédés dans des
conditions de nature à être approuvé par
la commission européenne comme vous le
dites
alors après reste deux préoccupations
centrales et croyez que elle ne me
quitte pas la première c'est celle de
ces foyers modestes qui cherchent une
offre de crédit que le chiffre est seul
était seul à pouvoir leur offrir
et en effet nous avons travaillé avec la
banque postale qui a repris l'activité
dit pas ce qui l'a fait monter en
puissance rapidement puisqu'à la fin du
premier semestre six cents millions
d'offres de prêts ont déjà été mises en
place qui permettent d'atteindre une
part de marché de 7 7%
l'objectif étant une production de passe
d'un milliard d'euros d'ici à fin 2013
c'est-à-dire autant que le cif en 2011
et donc par rapport à ça nous nous y
veillons et puis il ya la deuxième chose
qui me préoccupe évidemment c'est le
reclassement des salariés parce que je
connais et je les rencontre à chacun de
mes déplacements et je veille à le faire
leur très grande qualité
leur dévouement ce sont des personnels
qui sont souvent jeunes qui sont proches
du public et nous veillons à ce
reclassement il ne se passe pas une
réunion avec la fédération des banques
françaises sans que j'insiste sur ce
point il se trouve que demain la
fédération des banques françaises sera
reçu par le président de la république
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
sera question aussi du sort des salariés
du cif et l'activité et les salariés
voler ce qui nous préoccupe
alors que la droite le précédent
gouvernement avec complètement délaissé
et mis en sinistre cette activité est
hélas merci la parole à monsieur joël
billard pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur nellis de
l'intérieur monsieur demi nice dans la
nuit du 13 au 14 juillet la ville de
bonneval dont je fus maire a été le
théâtre de dégradations et
d'affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et une bande composée d'une
trentaine d'individus mineurs et majeurs
fortement alcoolisé ces individus s'en
sont pris à une vitrine puis là des
vrais d'habitation les gendarmes en
patrouille ont tenté de s'interposer et
de ramener de came sortis de leur
voiture ils ont été roués de coups
résultat de l'opération trois gendarmes
blessés et des dégradations sérieuse
dans ma ville il faut ajouter qu'un
gendarme interpellant un mineur se voit
le plus souvent taxé de brutalité ou de
maltraitance par les parents du mineur
le chu de nice cette situation est
proprement inadmissible inacceptable
s'attaquer aux forces de l'ordre c'est
le début d'anarchie et pour reprendre
l'expression célèbre général de gaulle
c'est la chienlit en effet qu attendent
d'une nation dont certains
ressortissants brûlent le drapeau
français
siph nocifs notre hymne national
siph le président de la république et ce
en toute impunité
et je ne vous parle pas de l'attitude
des gens du voyage peut-être serait-il
bon dans un premier temps que les
parents des dix mineurs soient
sanctionnés par exemple par la
suspension provisoire des allocations
familiales qui servent à élever les
enfants qui servent à élever les enfants
et non pas à les mettre dans la rue
de plus ayant pris un arrêté municipal
pour interdire la circulation des
mineurs non accompagnés sur l'ensemble
du territoire de la commune à partir de
22 heures
il m'a été demandé par les services de
l'état de le modifier en y apportant de
la souplesse demande incomprise et
rejeté par la population et les élus
je terminerai mon propos en soulignant
l'action courageuse des forces de
l'ordre ainsi que cette désintéresser
des cinq cent mille vies ne valent que
sont les élus de la république attendant
de votre part un soutien et un message
de fermeté
voici monsieur le ministre la situation
intolérable que je voulais vous exposer
merci la parole à madame najat vallaud
belkacem ministre et droits des femmes
porte parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le seul sénateur
permettez-moi d'excuser l'absence de
manuel valls qui est actuellement retenu
en lituanie pour un conseil justice et
affaires intérieures
revenons donc sur la sphère que vous
évoquez c'est vrai que votre commune a
été le théâtre d'une agression le 14
juillet dernier de trois gendarmes qui
effectué une patrouille de sécurisation
qui ont été victimes de quelques jeunes
en état d'ébriété vous l'avez rappelé
pour la plupart avant de revenir à ce
qui a été mis en oeuvre sur cette
affaire je voudrais d'abord commencé par
remercier et féliciter l'ensemble des
policiers des gendarmes des pompiers qui
sur un week-end aussi chargé comme on le
sait comme celui du 14 juillet ont un
peu partout en france fait en sorte que
les festivités se déroulent dans les
meilleures conditions
mais s'agissant de l'incident que vous
évoquez d'abord vous savez que trois
personnes ont été interpellées et que
ces personnes passeront au tribunal de
chartres cet après midi encore en
comparution immédiate
ensuite pour le reste de votre
interrogation le seul sénateur
je veux vous redire à quel point le
droit à la sécurité est un droit qui est
aujourd'hui promu et défendues par
l'ensemble du gouvernement à commencer
par le ministre de l'intérieur quel que
soit le territoire d'ailleurs dans
lequel on vit en milieu urbain
périurbain comment rural et c'est vrai
que si l'effort portant en particulier
sur les zones de sécurité prioritaire le
milieu rural n'est aucunement négliger
quand je regarde le département d'eure
et loir le vôtre les résultats sont même
plutôt encourageant j note par exemple
que les atteintes volontaires à
l'intégrité physique les violences aux
personnes sont en baisse de 10% au
premier semestre 2013
même si on doit encore faire mieux pour
prévenir les violences au sein des
familles les cambriolages qui étaient en
forte augmentation en 2012 sont
aujourd'hui quasiment maîtrisé
d'autres chiffres viennent confirmer
tout cela quant à vos deux
interrogations monsieur le sénateur sur
l'arrêté couvre-feu que vous avez voulu
prendre
cécile et l'action des élus en matière
d'insécurité est importante elle voit
quand même s'inscrire dans le cadre des
lois et donc il est naturel que les
préfets exercent
un contrôle de légalité quand les
mesures que vous prenez entre en
contradiction avec ce qui a été voté par
le législateur c'est ce qui s'est passé
les préfets ont un rôle de conseil au
maire et le gouvernement les conforte
totalement en ce sens quant à la
question des parents et de leurs
responsabilités quant aux agissements de
leurs enfants je vous rappelle que nous
prenons ici une responsabilité
individuelle et pas une responsabilité
collective
je veux remercier merci la parole à
monsieur jean louis carrère le président
carrère pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la défense monsieur le
ministre je souhaite en mon nom
personnel et au nom de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées vous interroger sur le
projet de loi de programmation militaire
qui vient d'être adopté en conseil de
défense et hier et qui après passage au
conseil d'état sera adopté par le
conseil des ministres le 2 août
comment faire en sorte que la loi de
programmation militaire s'inscrit
monsieur le ministre
dans la suite d'opérations réussies que
vous avez menée à bien avec le retrait
d'afghanistan l'opération serval au mali
et l'élaboration certes compliquée du
livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité
votre projet correspond pile au
paramètre parlementaire militaire et
industrielle d'une loi de programmation
militaire vertueuse pour le sénat pour
le parlement ce doit être une
programmation que nous pourrons
contrôler tout au long de son exécution
et vous savez combien sur tous les bancs
nous serons vigilants sur ce point pour
les armes et votre apn satisfait-elle
pleinement les contrats opérationnels
inscrit dans le livre blanc est elle
soutenable financièrement
de ce point de vue la question des
recettes exceptionnelles et
naturellement posée quelles dispositions
garantiront la pérennité de ces
ressources nous sommes très attachés ici
globalement à la réaffirmation de
l'objectif de 2% du pib' leur montant
dès que la situation économique le
permettra
en cas de retour à meilleure fortune
et puis le prévu une accélération de la
réalisation des programmes d'équipement
de nos forces
enfin la lpm doit préserver l'activité
opérationnelle des unités
qu'avez vous prévu monsieur le ministre
pour ce faire du point de vue des
industriels et j'en vois ici une lpm
virtuelle et une lpn qui m'aiment bien
l'effort de recherche une lpm qui fixe
des objectifs et un calendrier précis en
matière d'équipement avec des
financements sécurisés et qui préserve
la base industrielle et technologique de
la défense à chacun de ces paramètres
correspondant risques mais je voudrais
terminer par un sujet de préoccupation
majeur qui est celui des ressources
humaines les déflation à réaliser sont
très importantes
by me le restant de la précédente mpm et
24000 nouvelle nous sommes monsieur le
ministre d'avoir un obstacle important
comment accompagner cette déflation tout
en préservant l'opérationnel en
respectant les personnels et les
territoires vous avez monsieur le
ministre bénéficier par la qualité de
votre action et ce par votre
comportement vis-à-vis du sénat de notre
soutien actif je souhaite que cela se
poursuit merci monsieur le président la
parole à monsieur jean yves le drian
ministre de la défense
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président carrère vous avez raison de
rappeler le calendrier le conseil des
ministres dernier conseil des ministres
avant les vacances sera examiné le
projet de loi de programmation militaire
nous avons ainsi respecter totalement le
calendrier que je vous avait indiqué à
plusieurs reprises
et là le projet de loi de programmation
militaire sera dans la droite ligne du
livre blanc qui a fait l'objet ici au
sénat d'un débat et d'une déclaration du
premier ministre et ensuite il y aura un
débat parlementaire et une fois n'est
pas coutume dans ce domaine
mais ce sera au sénat que se fera la
première lecture de la loi de
programmation militaire
dès la rentrée
je voudrais en profiter pour vous dire
monsieur le président que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié le travail qui a été effectué
par la commission des affaires et en la
défense de du sénat vous avez publié sur
tous les bancs vous avez publié beaucoup
de recommandations beaucoup de travaux
et je suis convaincu que vous vous
retrouverez dans les inflexion
significative corps à ses doigts
programmation militaire
par exemple sur la cyberdéfense lacune
majeure à laquelle il nous faut remédier
par exemple sur le renseignement et la
loi de programmation militaire reprendra
une bonne partie des conclusions de
votre commission concernant les drones
par exemple sur les forces spéciales par
exemple sur la nécessité de nous doter
d'avions ravitailleurs par exemple sur
la nécessité de renforcer la sécurité
maritime l'ensemble de ces inflexions
seront à sera inscrit dans la loi de
programmation militaire je ne vais pas
là maintenant puisqu'il est ce document
et au conseil détail n'est pas encore
approuvé par le conseil des ministres
vous en donner le détail je voulais
simplement vous dire que par rapport à
certaines de vos préoccupations il y
aura bien une réexamen de la situation
fin 2015
il y aura une clause de revoyure à ce
moment là en souhaitant que les
conditions économiques soient alors
meilleur qu'aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
dire aussi que j'ai décidé de
sanctuariser au sein des crédits
budgétaires que me seront affectés eu un
montant significatif d'intervention dans
le domaine de l'innovation et de la
recherche qui sera le même montant que
cette année pendant les trois années qui
suivent
et enfin je n'ai aucune raison de
revenir sur les déclarations du
président de la république et du premier
ministre
ici même par lesquels ils affichaient
leur volonté de garantir le premier
lorsqu'il y avait le débat sur le livre
blanc de garantir les un montant
significatif des ressources budgétaires
pour le budget de la défense pour les
trois années qui viennent au même niveau
que l'année 2013 et enfin de garantir la
sécurité des ressources exceptionnelles
merci messieurs le mini
la parole est à monsieur dominique de
legge pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire sur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres la
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du budget la réunion qui s'est
tenue avant-hier avec les associations
d'élus à laquelle d'ailleurs le premier
ministre a fait allusion tout à l'heure
a été présenté comme l'illustration du
pacte de confiance et de responsabilité
voulue par le président de la république
pour qu'il y ait confiance il faut
respecter sa parole et ne pas changer de
discours en fonction des circonstances
nous sommes de ceux qui ont toujours
pensé que les collectivités
territoriales ne pouvait pas s'exonérer
l'effort de maîtrise de la dépense
publique
lorsqu'un autre gouvernement avait
envisagé de diminuer les dotations aux
collectivités territoriales de 200
millions toutes les grandes associations
d'élus n'avait pas de mots assez forts
pour dénoncer ce qu'elle appelait à
l'époque halde l'état annonce
aujourd'hui par la voix de ceux là mêmes
qui hier étaient les plus véhéments sur
le sujet une diminution des dotations de
1 milliard et demi et ces mêmes
responsables ne trouve rien à redire
il y a quelques semaines le président de
la république déclarait que la hausse
des impôts c'était fini le 14 juillet il
annonçait qu'il ferait tout pour
l'éviter mais qu'on ne pouvait rien
exclu monsieur le ministre de l'économie
a déclaré il ya peu de temps qu'il
faudrait sans doute augmenter les impôts
monsieur le premier ministre prenant
connaissance 25 juin dernier d'un
rapport de la cour des comptes sur la
dérive du déficit budgétaire déclaré je
le cite je pense que pour 2013
malheureusement du fait de l'absence de
croissance
ce que dit la cour est vrai mais on
verra à la fin de l'année alors qui
croire c'est bien un problème de
confiance pour qu'il y ait
responsabilité il faut aussi assumer ses
décisions et leurs conséquences je n'ai
pas le sentiment que ce soit le cas
lorsque vous renvoyer la facture aux
collectivités territoriales sur le rsa
l'information professionnelle ou les
rythmes scolaires
le comble c'est de présenter comme un
effort de l'état la possibilité que vous
donnez aux départements
déplafonner le taux de prélèvement ddmt
au vous ne leur donnez rien vous les
insultez simplement augmenter la
fiscalité locale pour financer vos
décisions
mais le malheur veut qu'il n'y ait point
deux contribuables
l'un nationale et l'autre local je n'ai
pas vu dans les décisions d'avant-hier
la volonté de maîtriser la dépense
publique tout au plus elle de vous
défoncer alors monsieur le ministre de
questions
oui ou non faute ils s'attendent à une
nouvelle hausse de la fiscalité et ne
nous dites pas que vous ne savez pas ce
accréditerait la thèse d'un pilotage à
vue
oui ou non allez vous enfin vous
attaquer à la réduction des dépenses
publiques et n'a voté par l'héritage
parce que au fond vous donner au travers
de ça le sentiment d'impuissance et le
sentiment vous ne croyez pas au
changement
merci monsieur de lège monsieur bernard
cazeneuve monsieur sénateur je vous
remercie infiniment pour être question
qui va me donner l'occasion de vous
rappeler un certain nombre d'éléments
qui ont dû vous échapper
et tout d'abord monsieur le sénateur
vous parlez de la dépense publique mais
vous en parler de façon tellement
savante qui n'a pas dû échapper à votre
sagacité qu'elle augmentait 170
milliards entre 2007 et 2012 170
milliards d'augmentation de la dépense
publique
il n'a pas non plus échappé à votre
sagacité qu'entre 2007 et 2012 le
déficit public a augmenté de 2%
il n'a pas échappé non plus à votre
sagacité qu'entre 2007 et 2012 le
déficit des comptes sociaux s'est creusé
de façon abyssale et j'imagine que vous
êtes tout à fait conscient également que
la compétitivité de notre économie c'est
à ce point dégradée qu'alors que vous
avez laissé un déficit du commerce
extérieur à 0 en 2002 il est aujourd'hui
65 milliards là où l'allemagne affiche
un excédent de 150 milliards quand on a
un tel palmarès
on peut comme vous l'avez fait donner
des leçons tranquillement à ceux qui
hérite d'une situation
extraordinairement difficile et qui
s'emploie à la corriger
alors je voudrais maintenant parler plus
particulièrement des collectivités
territoriales parce que nous n'aurions
pas nous n'aurions pas appelé les
collectivités qu'on locales à
contribution si vous n'aviez pas laisser
une telle situation mais sans doute sans
doute vous souvient-il monsieur
sénateurs que pendant la campagne
électorale
celui qui était en charge de
l'élaboration du programme de votre
formation avait proposées comprennent va
10 milliards sur les collectivités
locales
à l'époque vous applaudissent y est
quand vous proposé de prélever 10
milliards c'est le paradis quand on en
prélève un milliard cinq pour faire face
à la situation où nous avait laissés
c'est l'enfer je dois contre je dois
vous avouer que j'ai quelques
difficultés à accéder à ce raisonnement
enfin troisièmement je vais prendre
catégories de collectivités locales par
catégorie de collectivités locales comme
ça vous pourrez partir de cet hémicycle
en étant totalement tranquilliser sur
les décisions que nous avons prises et
la situation que nous allons créer aussi
concerne d'abord les départements mais
monsieur le sénateur
si vous n'aviez pas créer les conditions
d'un effet de ciseau dramatique pour les
départements si les départements
n'étaient pas confrontés aujourd'hui à
l'obligation de financer des dépenses
exceptionnelles des dépenses contraintes
qui s'appelle le rsa la pch
hélas pas avec des ressources que vous
avez constamment diminué au cours des
dernières années nous n'aurions pas été
dans l'obligation au terme d'un
excellent accord avec les présidents de
départements dont vos propres familles
se sont félicités dont certains sont
dans cet hémicycle je pense notamment à
monsieur béchu qui était hier et
monsieur béchu qui était hier à cette
réunion qui est président de conseil
général de la sarthe ump qui a remercié
le gouvernement pour le travail qu'il a
fait qui a indiqué d'ailleurs que si ce
travail avait été fait au cours des dix
dernières années
il aurait eu le plaisir de féliciter le
gouvernement qu'il soutenait mais vous
lui avait pas donné ce plaisir parce que
vous avez laissé la situation des
départements se dégrader et bien ce que
nous faisons c'est de compenser les
départements hauteur de 800 millions
d'euros et de leur offrir la possibilité
à travers les dm théo de faire face à
leurs charges et pour ce qui concerne
les régions nous offrons aux régions un
panier de ressources dynamiques qui leur
permettra de jouer leur rôle leader en
matière de développement économique
vous avez creusé les déficits monsieur
min en soyons redresser la cie
la france et nous accompagnons les
collectivités locales dans leur
développe
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame claudine lepage pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre délégué
chargé du budget depuis l'été dernier le
gouvernement est mobilisé sur un front
stratégique au coeur des engagements
pris par le président de la république
le logement les objectifs ambitieux
construire 500 mille logements par an
dont 150 mille logements sociaux sont
aussi nécessaires au regard des besoins
de la population du niveau de rétention
foncière atteint et des difficultés du
secteur du bâtiment en annonçant mi juin
une réforme de la fiscalité des plus
values réalisées à l'occasion de
cessions immobilières
le président de la république a confirmé
son complète engagement pour la réussite
du choc d'offre dont le secteur a besoin
les mesures initiées par la droite ont
contribué à accroître la rétention des
biens en encourageant fiscalement les
propriétaires à garder leur terrain le
plus longtemps possible
ce système a été désastreux pour le
marché de l'immobilier
tous les professionnels du secteur le
savent pour lutter contre les
comportements de rétention il faut au
contraire encourager les propriétaires à
vendre dans un délai court sur le
logement les abattements seront donc
allégées et les durée raccourcie par
ailleurs car la crise du secteur
demandent des mesures rapides une
mesures d'abattement exceptionnel sur
les cessions a été annoncée pour 2014
la fluidification du marché est
aujourd'hui une urgence nationale
et cette mesure va dans le bon sens à
quelques semaines de la présentation du
projet de loi de finances pour 2014
je souhaiterais monsieur le ministre que
vous puissiez nous apporter des
précisions sur cette réforme et
notamment son calendrier d'application
je vous remercie par ailleurs pour la
réponse que vous m'apporterait dans les
semaines qui viennent
concernant le problème spécifique de
l'ach de l'assujettissement aux
prélèvements sociaux
des plus values de cessions immobilières
et des loyers perçus par les non
résidents
cette réforme de juillet 2012 a en effet
suscité une polémique chez les français
de l'étranger qu'il me semble important
de clore rapidement
merci madame lepage monsieur le ministre
madame la sénatrice vous m'invitez à
travers votre question à faire un point
sur la réforme des plus values
immobilières dans laquelle le président
de la république et le premier ministre
ont souhaité que nous nous engagions
pour favoriser les constructions de
logements pour fluidifier le marché pour
faire en sorte que ceux qui ont le
souhait d'accéder à la propriété ou qui
ont vocation à être locataires de
logements puissent le faire dans des
conditions financières qui n'obère pas
leur pouvoir d'achat nous avons donc
décidé de modifier comme vous l'avez
signalé à l'instant le régime applicable
aux plus values immobilières il faut
rappeler vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit dans
votre question qu'en 2011 ce régime a
été modifié la période d'exonération
totale pour les plus values immobilières
était de 15 ans elle a été passée à 30
ans et le régime d'abattement qui a été
mis en place et des d'autant plus
favorable que la durée de détention et
est longue ce qui était une incitation
pour les propriétaires d'immeubles à
garder ses immeubles longtemps là où on
a au contraire besoin dans la crise
d'avoir de la rotation d'avoir un marché
fluide qui permet d'engager des travaux
est d'accompagner le secteur de bâtiment
dans son redressement là où il est
confronté à une crise extrêmement
important nous avons donc décidé de
mettre en place un nouveau régime de
plus values immobilières que je veux en
quelques mots rappelé désormais c'est au
bout de 22 ans et non plus de trente ans
que vous serez totalement exonérés à
l'impôt sur le revenu pour les plus
values que vous aurez réalisé au bout de
30 ans vous serez exonéré non seulement
sur l'impôt sur le revenu mais également
sur les contributions sociales notamment
la csg avec un dispositif d'abattement
beaucoup plus linéaire beaucoup plus
dégressif et qui facilitera les sessions
par ailleurs de manière à avoir un
véritable choc d'offre vous avez vous
même évoqué cette expression cette
proposition il a été décidé de mettre en
place entre
le 1er septembre 2014 le pardon 1er
septembre 2013 et le 31 août 2014 un
abattement exceptionnelle de 25 % qui
favorisera les transactions favorisera
les travaux favorisera les ventes pour
atteindre l'objectif de développement de
l'activité autour du secteur du bâtiment
et pour faire en sorte aussi de
favoriser l'accessibilité au logement et
par ailleurs je veux vous indiquer que
la décision a été prise de mettre 20 aux
en bateau a bêtement pour détention de
propriété foncière de manière à
favoriser la vente de terrains et à
faire en sorte que nous puissions avoir
davantage de constructions de logements
neufs dans les mois qui viennent voilà
le programme global que nous proposons
qui va être engagée à partir des
semaines qui viennent par instruction
puis l'ensemble ces dispositions sont
dans la loi de finances pour faire en
sorte que dans la crise
nous accompagnons la croissance et
notamment la croissance dans le secteur
du bâtiment dont on sait le rôle moteur
qu'il joue dans l'économie
merci monsieur ministre 1 et bien
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous en avons fini avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 voilà donc pour cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement en direct on se retrouve
tout de suite pour refaire ensemble à
tes enfants
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat après la séance cet
après-midi des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
on revient sur les tous les thèmes
abordés par les sénateurs qui ont
interpellé le gouvernement et notre
première invitée aujourd'hui bien c'est
nicole bricq
la ministre chargée du commerce
extérieur bonjour ans ancienne sénatrice
et vous reviendrai peut-être sénatrice
après votre sortie du gouvernement le
plus longtemps possible j'espère pour
vous si on revient un petit peu sur
l'entretien accordé par françois
hollande le 14 juillet un françois
hollande optimiste envers et contre tous
c'est ce que vous partagez cet optimisme
quand il assure et bien que la reprise
économique est en vie quand on attend du
président de la république qu'il montre
la voie qu il